there's so many people out there that
would look at you right now coming out
with this movie and having the career
that you have that would say
um okay Billy how do I get where you are
how do I
how do I achieve what you've achieved
and one of the things that you've done
that I'm a big believer is that you took
control you
there's so many people that say well I'm
just going to put myself out there as an
actor and I'm going to put my headshot
out there I'm going to go to auditions
and it's a very passive way to approach
this business and I was always
comfortable
with anything that'll that where I could
use some of my abilities to control the
situation a little bit as a writer as
someone who could think of something for
myself and I look at you and I think you
with with Billy on the Street and
because you existed at a time of you
know social media uh YouTube you were
able to create something yourself
that gave you all these other
opportunities yeah for sure I mean
I started out you know I went to
Northwestern I was a theater major you
know I just wanted to be kind of a
typical actor I never even thought of
myself as a writer or a comedian
um then I got to New York I mean I grew
up in New York and then after college
went back to New York to start my career
quote-unquote and you know there's
millions of people trying to be actors
and I realized very early on that if I
just stood in line waiting at this open
call with hundreds of other actors for
like the regional tour of Brigadoon or
whatever it was which I didn't even want
to do although shout out to the everyone
in the cast of the regional Torah
brigadoo they're wonderful I don't want
to do what you're doing but shout out
yeah
um I find the way you've spent your life
a waste of time that's not what is your
problem that is not what I said but um
it's just not what I wanted to do yes
yeah and a never-ending Purgatory no I'm
kidding please this is on me now not on
you I no seriously love I love the
current touring cast of Brigadoon no I
don't know if that's even touring right
now but um I'm not here to talk about
Brigadoon
um let me get this straight so Billy's
Billy's
it's about a magical land wait a minute
I got that wrong so I I basically
started to write for myself and
and I was good at it and I had a live
stage show that I did in New York which
is where the Billy on the Street video
started I would show those videos on a
screen this is before YouTube even
existed this is like 2004 2005.
um but then an interesting thing
happened where a lot of folks in the
industry would come and they would
acknowledge that I was talented or that
they thought I was funny that the
audience was laughing a lot that I was
unique and this that and the other thing
but it was always you know we don't know
what to do with you right or you're very
New York and a lot of times in both
overt ways and subtle ways I was sent
the message that I I was just too gay
yeah right I was being openly gay on
stage I was talking about gay sex now
everyone's talking about gay sex but
this is 2003 right even this is back
when you were losing roles to dinosaurs
exactly dinosaurs were [ __ ] on screen
but I wasn't alive
okay brontosaurus on stegosaurus was
fine yeah was fine a lot of Fanboys
jerking off to that but two actual
humans having sex who happened to be men
was alienating
so that message was sent to me many
times but then what happened was the
internet came along and I put my videos
online and after a little while they
went viral and very viral and I was able
to point to all of those people in the
industry and say hey I'm not to this or
to that this video has millions of views
right these views aren't coming
exclusively from gay people watching a
New York City look at the comments
they're coming from all over the country
and all over the world and that's when
they finally put me on TV I needed those
numbers to point to and say hey I have
proof that I am not this little niche
thing that you assume I am because I'm
gay do you ever think about let's say
somehow there's a whatever Wrinkle in
Time and you're born uh in the 30s or
whatever you come of age in the 40s or
1950s and you have all the talent and
ability you have now but there's no
internet there's no there's no YouTube
there's no way to you yourself take
control do you know what you would have
become I don't know
you know I think about that all the time
and you know
it's just and that weighed really
heavily on me during the movie and if
you see the movie I don't want to give
it away but I do speak to this at one
point you know I'm 43 years old so when
the movie comes out I'll be 44 so I'm
kind of in the in this interesting
Midway point between a generation of
lgbtq people and gay men specifically
who really saw the world change like
when they grew up it was such a
repressed time they a lot of them
probably probably can't even imagine the
world that we live in today you know
even though there are still problems and
we're still fighting for our rights
still the evolution that has occurred is
really remarkable right they live
through the AIDS epidemic there's a lot
to unpack there then you have a younger
generation now and you see them all over
the place of lgbtq people and gen Z
queer kids which is amazing but they
stepped into such a different world such
an an evolved accepting world and again
a world where thing thanks to Clarence
Thomas another like [ __ ] up homophobic
you know self-loathing weirdos like
we're still fighting for our rights and
our rights are still very fragile but
again that generation a lot to do with
the internet you know came of age in a
time when
you know things were if not easy a lot
easier and I'm kind of weirdly perched
in between these two generations that
have had a very different experience
being lgbtq and I wanted the movie
to speak to that in a way because we
need to acknowledge and by the way I'm
making the movie sound like [ __ ] you
know Out of Africa or something like
it's like it sounds so [ __ ] serious
this is a funny Judd Apatow movie
everybody
um it's dinosaurs it's Sonic the
Hedgehog it's everything you want it to
be but just speaking about it seriously
for a moment because it is a historic
movie
um you know you do have to acknowledge
those generations of people and
Hollywood especially in Industry which
has so often patted itself on the back
for being Progressive and a gay friendly
quote-unquote you know Holly it's a
cliche to say that like everyone in
Hollywood is gay you know that it's this
Progressive Lefty you know culture but
really when you look at the actual
history of it just voting for a Democrat
doesn't mean that you are treating lgbtq
people correctly on the day-to-day and
what you see in Hollywood are
generations of actors who were stuck
with one of two choices be incredibly
bold and come out of the closet publicly
and have your professional dreams
disappear because Hollywood did not give
opportunities to people they did not
believe gay could play straight they did
not believe gay people want like that
that the majority of the audience wanted
to see gay people at all okay they made
people uncomfortable if you did get a
role it was horror horribly
stereotypical you were the butt of the
joke and that was for many years the
best you were gonna do right or you had
to live some Rock Hudson style life
where if you wanted a big career as a
movie star or TV star especially if you
wanted to play straight roles which were
the only roles that really existed at
the time you had to live this weird
double life pretend you were dating
women publicly and then secretly live
your live your secret gay life that you
were not supposed to talk about you know
that you could go live in some weird gay
Enclave somewhere when no one was
looking when the cameras weren't on and
I can only imagine that's the best those
guys could do that's what they were
offered like those were their choices
but what horrible choices to have to
make yeah right and now I don't have to
make those choices right and Bros is
really a moment to celebrate
the fact that we have come a really long
way that the entire movie is made up of
openly lgbtq actors the entire cast it's
a first this movie is a first in many
ways and that's one of them and that's
when you look at the history of it you
know a 20 year old queer kid now who may
not know the history may say oh all
right well I see gay people everywhere
they're all over my phone they're all
over TV but if you know the history of
Hollywood especially major Studio
filmmaking that is huge that is a huge
moment it's very hard I mean and also I
think you're making the point and I
would agree that
um it it it's impossible to expect
someone who's 20 or 22 today to
completely understand because they just
haven't lived it yeah but so much has
changed
um you know I'm a good a good deal older
than you and I've just watched there
there'd be such a evolution in how
people talk about
you know not just the lgbtq community
but race uh class so many things have
evolved and it doesn't mean we we okay
we did it let's all high five each other
we're done it has to keep going we have
to keep but uh it is it is a positive in
a world of negativity it is a positive
perspective to have yeah that these
things have changed and young people you
know uh today maybe they can be
impatient for it should be better than
it is right away and I understand that
and maybe that's really important that's
the rocket fuel it's like okay you guys
think this is you know look how far
we've come I don't care about that
because I'm 22 and I think this is the
least of where we should be yeah which
is probably the right perspective I do
get inspired by that generation though
because I always thought I was very bold
and outspoken but they really push the
boundaries especially when it comes to
sex and being very open about it and
queer sex and gay sex and and I
sometimes see what's post on Instagram
from my younger gay friends and I'm like
wow okay so suddenly you're the old
school mom no exactly no I'm like I
don't think that's a perfect I'm like
Mrs Garrett
and they're like Judy and Natalie
Running Wild on
Road throughout the house and I'm like
girls I don't know if this is okay
but it is okay you're the modern Mrs
Garrett yes I've always wondered what is
Billy you're the Mrs Garrett of our time
you nailed IP Charlotte Ray we both went
to Northwestern by the way
um and if only Mrs Garrett were alive to
see Bros put that on the poster
but no they're so the younger kids the
younger queer kids are inspiring me it's
like okay we can have a few sex scenes
and Bros and people will will Embrace
that and it's actually really fun and
exciting and it's okay we don't have to
be scared of that anymore and
um I'm I'm happy I I need that push from
that generation myself a little bit